grace and peace to you all a special
welcome to the families of our students
you're always welcome here and we are
here every Sunday year-round break or
term time you're always welcome we enjoy
your participation but I do have to give
you one basic warning that I give every
year that if after the service when
we're in back having coffee and you walk
up and introduce yourselves to me and I
don't immediately recognize your son or
daughter I promise it's only my bad
memory to blame it has nothing doesn't
say anything about whether they've been
here to worship every week or not I just
don't have a terrible time with names
and faces it seems as though every
family weekend we have a gospel text
that isn't exactly the warm and fuzzy
sentiment that we would hope for I think
last year it was Jesus saying that you
had to hate your mother and father if he
wanted to get into the kingdom of God
not a good start I think another year
which Jesus saying that you had to sell
all you have and give to the poor which
is not a parent's favorite text they're
hoping that you will go on to great
things though some parents may feel that
they are living Jesus's teaching as they
sign those tuition checks today Jesus
tells us a deceptively simple parable
that I want to focus on and it says as
Andre just read so beautifully two men
went up to the temple to pray one was a
Pharisee and the other was a tax
collector I was thinking about making
students act this out but I thought
they'll be too embarrassing the Pharisee
is standing by himself was praying thus
god I thank you that I am not like other
people thieves rogues adulterers or even
like this tax collector I fast twice a
week I give a tenth of all my income but
the tax collector and I'm imagining the
Pharisee somewhere up there with the
quartet sorry I'm imagining the tax
collector somewhere back here somewhere
back in that dark corner standing afar
off who would not even look up to heaven
but was beating his breasts and saying
God be merciful to me a sinner and Jesus
concludes by saying I tell you this man
the tax collector went home justified
rather than the Pharisee for all who
exalt themselves will be humbled but all
who humble themselves will be exalted
now we all agree that Jesus seems too
deeply valued humility but I wonder
where humility is in our midst after all
we're here in a room full of students
who work for 18 years to polish a resume
to get into a place like Yale whose most
visible quality was probably not
humility so how can we live in a world
that requires us to promote ourselves
when Jesus says that those who praise
themselves will be humbled and those who
humble themselves will be praised I
think this parable is a trap and Jesus
was an expert at these sort of homespun
tales that start so nice and you say
okay I know where I am this sounds good
and suddenly there's a sharp barb at the
end that sticks you I think they're
meant to low us to sleep and then wake
us up but this story is a setup from the
very beginning first the Pharisee over
centuries we've misread Jesus's words
and so we've come to think of Pharisees
as self-righteous and smug elitist and
exclusive something bad to be a Pharisee
sort of like our friends at a certain
institution in Cambridge Massachusetts
but
but the miss reading of the Pharisees is
untrue as the stereotype of our crimson
clad brothers and sisters the parable
doesn't work unless the Pharisee is a
person who does all the right things you
really have to believe that if the
parable is going to work he fasts when
the Bible commands he faithfully pays
his time he doesn't lie or cheat or
steal or cheat on his wife he's a good
citizen and a faithful believer that's
the Pharisee the tax collector on the
other hand is someone who's already been
cast out of the community for very good
reasons he collaborates with your
pressing Empire he grinds down the poor
he cheats on his duties and takes extra
money from the people he's the bad guy
and so Jesus shows us both men in the
temple praying and if the story were
normal the story should say that God
sees and recognizes the Pharisee who has
always done the right thing and he goes
away rewarded and the tax collector
who's always done the wrong thing should
certainly be punished that's just fair
that's the way the world should work
what kind of preacher would your parents
think I am if they heard that I was
telling you that God rewards bad
behavior and punishes good behavior they
pull you right out of Yale it would be
bad it would just confirm the legends
out there that the Ivy League schools
are all about destroying homegrown
values that's what we hear but Jesus as
always refuses to give the simple
message be good and God will reward you
instead he insists on looking beyond our
behavior to study our motivation and
this is where it always gets tricky for
the Pharisee though he is truly
righteous and is doing all the things a
good man is supposed to do seems to be
doing them for all the wrong reasons and
here in the parable in the presence of
God in the temple he seems to be busy
not thinking about God he's busy looking
around himself and comparing his virtues
to everyone else's failures I'm better
than him hmmm better than her
no much better than him Oh incredibly
better than her I don't even make me
laugh about him while the tax collector
off in the dark corner far from the holy
place doesn't even see anybody else he
knows he's wrong to even be in the
temple and all he sees and feels is the
presence of a holy and just God and it
doesn't make him feel good he beats his
breast as only women did at funerals and
praise God have mercy on me a sinner and
who leaves justified by God the bad man
over and over again Jesus tells his
disciples that the goodness of good
behavior can be cancelled by bad
motivation really hard idea he never
says good behavior isn't good or even
important but he keeps saying that it's
what's in your heart that ultimately
matters to God not what you do good
deeds done for bad reasons lose their
goodness but the trap of the parable is
just beginning because the stinger comes
when we the hearers look at this scene
with the Pharisee and the tax collector
and ask ourselves who's the villain was
in an obvious it's the Pharisee right
that's what Jesus is teaching us he's
judgmental he's condescending he's so
proud of being good and that's where the
trap Springs and Jesus's got us because
we hear ourselves say the words thank
God I am not like this Pharisee I'm not
judgmental of others I don't condemn I'm
inclusive I vote for the right candidate
I have all the right opinions and there
we are right in the Pharisees shoes we
thought we were the tax collector humble
and beloved of God but at the moment we
state the inevitable conclusion of the
parable we find ourselves smack where we
don't want to be in the shoes of the
Pharisee taking Jesus seriously is
always a dangerous thing
you can find yourself all tied up in
knots I try to do the right things in my
life I try to be fair honest kind
hard-working I even try to stretch
myself to understand other people who
are different from me and I often fail
but I do try but for Jesus goodness
isn't enough we have to want to be good
not to please other people not to please
even our parents not because we're
afraid of what other people will think
or even to feel good or look good to
others but only only only because it is
God that wants this from us last
saturday Saturday and rabbi Marc
Gilman's column in the local paper he
printed a letter from a reader that said
in part my wife and I recently relocated
from the Midwest to California and were
having a tough time finding a new church
and at the risk of sounding like a
sacrilegious Goldilocks we're having
trouble finding a church that's just
right for us after visiting one church
here several times our impression was
that the member spent an unreasonable
amount of time congratulating themselves
on how great they were for being
inclusive as opposed to acknowledging
the God who made them so wonderful I was
studying this parable at the time I read
this column and I thought same old story
but it keeps hitting closer and closer
to home of course the reader who wrote
the letter had some issues about being
judgmental too and thankfully especially
about preachers thankfully rabbi
government set them straight but can
churches or universities or even nations
fall into jesus' trap can we start out
doing something because it's right and
end up doing it because it makes us feel
good about ourselves or helps us feel
better than other people I wonder some
of the nausea many in America are
feeling about the current election
campaigns is an example no matter how
righteous true or virtuous a candidate
is perhaps all those qualities can be
cancelled out by one sleazy personal ad
so I started wondering if the tax
collector of our parable for running
we're running for office what would
their television ads sound like and this
is what I imagine I'm ed Malone and I
approve this message you've heard me say
I deserve your vote but can you really
trust me four years ago I ran on a
platform that supported universal health
care but when the bill came out I didn't
like it much and there were a lot of
powerful lobbyists who gave me money so
that I would vote against it can you
really trust someone like me to
represent you then there was the
all-expense-paid trip to Aruba for me
and Martha and the five kids that was
secretly paid for by the mining company
that's regulated by my committee I med
ballon and I say you can't trust ed
Malone paid for by the EDD Malone for
Congress Committee the only way out of
Jesus is trap is to do what the tax
collector does is to throw ourselves on
the mercy of the court there's no escape
from our humaneness which somehow can
turn any virtue no matter how humble
into the vice of feeling superior to
other people as humans we can turn any
gold into straw or good at it virtues
like hard work and organization and even
service to others even in fact humility
we can take them from being good things
and turned them into bad things through
our motivation father John Shea quotes
an old Catholic story that could easily
be Protestant about a church where the
priest in the Deacon are up at the altar
praying and the priest looking like the
perfect clergyman looks up to heaven and
says in a sonorous and deeply serious
voice forgive me God for I am a sinner
and the Deacon trying to capture just a
piece of the priest holiness also in
tones forgive me God for I am a sinner
and in their moment of deep
contemplation they hear a voice from the
to the church and they see the cleaning
lady kneeling by her mop bucket weeping
and saying forgive me God for I am a
sinner and the priest turns the deacon
and says look who thinks she's a sinner
what the tax collector gets right is
that God is merciful we hear it in
longing words of today's reading from
Jeremiah which says we acknowledge our
wickedness Oh God for we have sinned
against you do not spurn us for your
namesake do not dishonor yourself but
remember and do not break your covenant
with us God has made and remade
covenants that bind even God by God's
own action to be merciful to us even
when we don't deserve any kind of mercy
in creation god made a covenant with us
by crafting each and all of us by hand
when humans became conscious of good and
evil and learned the arts of oppression
and violence God did not abandon God's
children but covenant it not to let us
destroy ourselves when we became nations
and people's God showed us through
Abraham and Sarah how even if a nation
turned on its own principles God would
still honor the Covenant and in Jesus
Christ God made a new covenant with all
humanity for to forgive sins and restore
us to gods family God knows we wonder
that we try to do good and somehow turn
it all into selfishness God has promised
to be merciful in spite of God's own
holiness and justice because God loves
us so even when we go wrong God promises
mercy long ago I read a classic
spiritual book called the way of the
pilgrim some of you probably read it an
anonymous 19th century Russian book and
the book describes in part a method of
prayer that suggests living out
Estonians command to pray without
ceasing by actually repeating over and
over and over again a simple prayer the
book said to repeat it over and over and
over again so much so that even if we
were you doing other things it was still
running in your head the whole time I
thought it was a very strange idea but
then I was a Texas Methodist long ways
away from Russian Orthodox repeating a
prayer that that way sounded sort of
mystical magical wasn't quite so sure
but as I contemplate this parable the
idea begins to make
because as my go through my day at each
turn I risk falling into this parables
trap the woman in front of me at dunkin
donuts she isn't dressed well enough the
old man driving in front of me is a
nuisance the homeless man on the green
on my walk to the office scares me my
officemate is cranky my students don't
show up for a meeting they're
irresponsible other christians on campus
of course are not as inclusive and
loving as I am so I wonder if perhaps I
repeated this prayer over and over and
over and over again as I went through my
day I might not have time to worry about
what's so wrong with other people and
the prayer simply says over and over
again Jesus Christ have mercy on me a
sinner